[Music]
concerning the brexit negotiations the
phase of negotiations have been quite
intense the last days our main focus is
a presidency and that's also what I
promised to Michelle bond you in various
phone calls is that we make an effort to
maintain the unity of the 27 which is
absolutely key especially in this moment
we will continue to support Michelle
bond Diaz chief negotiator because we
want to have a deal
with Great Britain and this is only
possible if the European Union as 27
stick together on Hungary after
receiving the information from the
Parliament the presidency informed about
procedural questions we have agreed that
we can invite Hungary to make a written
statement which have agreed to we also
invited the Commission to present us an
up-to-date factual overview of
infringement procedures in recent years
on issues and issues raised and angry by
the European Parliament a couple of
words about the continued dialogue on
Poland the article 7 procedure I have to
say sadly things have not improved they
have deteriorated in our analysis
especially disappointing I find the fact
that although now there is a procedure
before the European Court of Justice the
Polish authorities have not used the
fact that there is this procedure to
stop the implementation of the reform of
the Supreme Court and have actually
speeded up that process by nominating
ever more judges on that Court I still
hope that at some point we can have a
constructive dialogue and we can find
solutions for the issues at hand so that
we can ensure that the rule of law is
still maintained in all Member States
[Music]
you